again I've been in software for 30 years
now doing startups pretty much my entire
professional career
the only time I've felt like
like how hard palpitations kind of like
Sean kind of open with us like there's
this party going on next door and I'm
here knitting right it's like this is
like too big to ignore I think it's the
single largest opportunity and biggest
kind of uh Tech Paradigm Shift we've
seen uh since the internet originally
came out like mobile was big but there
was a discreet set of use cases like
when you put a camera on a phone when
you put a GPS device on a phone a bunch
of consumer apps like uber and others
came up and that was awesome right but
it was not like this impacts everything
like the internet did right it's like
okay there's some businesses some new
opportunities lots of good things lots
of money made lots of startups awesome
this is an order of magnitude bigger
than that
foreign
[Music]
what's up we have darmesh back darmesh
who is co-founder of HubSpot and uh
multiple time guests on the Pod one of
the one of the fan favorites you're back
and I don't know what we're gonna talk
about because usually we have these
little like cheat sheets where it's like
um three or three to five bullet points
of interesting ideas topics experiments
you've been running things like that and
I'm sure you have those but I don't have
the cheat sheet so where do you want to
start
I say we start with
generative AI because I don't know if
you've heard but there's this thing
called chat GP I get this question from
my friends and family all the time he's
like darmesh have you checked out this
chat gtt thing I'm like really do you
even know me like At first I played with
it I've been obsessed um ever since it
came out so did you see I want to talk
about your topics but really quick did
you see did you guys see this that so
Sam Altman co-founded openai he's like
the The Man In Charge I read an article
where he was quoted as saying like I
have enough money and I don't want
equity in the company and I don't know
if I entirely believe that but that's
wild if true because it could be one of
the more valuable companies in the world
the next 10 years yeah he didn't I don't
know if he said it like he didn't say it
on the record on the record but the
person reporting it said Sam reportedly
has no equity in the uh the for-profit
version of openai because he's already
wealthy enough and didn't want to uh
didn't feel like he needed to or didn't
want to didn't want to have that
clouding his judgment when it came to
this and like this is pretty you're
gonna bet what what one private company
what one private startup is most likely
to become worth a trillion dollars or
more
I think at this point that has to be
open AI right now is that right like
dermis would you would you disagree with
that it it'd be up there the top three
okay I honestly can't think of
who else would rank higher in terms of
probability of getting the top three and
I don't know what two and three are yeah
well who are the other two and three you
know I'm you know I don't know I was
like
no I I would say that was the
transformative one right I think
um you know a lot of the kind of Tesla
gains we've sort of seen I'm not sure if
there's like big surprises left it's
like okay they will make it better
they'll get to full self-driving and
we'll see kind of progress on that front
but in terms of just raw valuation
um it's the wild card opening eyes the
one that
could actually pull out and they get
they get a lot of [__] because people
are saying like um
like you know Elon kind of is stoking
this fire like how did this non-profit
go to a four Pro how did this open
sourced non-profit company research lab
basically become a for-profit
semi-closed uh you know the company and
I think that's people are going to make
people are going to take shots and make
fun of openai because it's clearly the
new powerful thing that's so some people
are gonna say how it's going to ruin the
world and how terrible they are uh but
he did give it there was a story that
came out with a good explanation which
was
they were burning a lot of money in the
research lab
they needed more money
um Elon was gonna be the big backer so
he was going to pledge or commit a
billion dollars to it he
um
and then he was like no I don't like the
way this is going like Google is way
ahead and
um I'm gonna take over open Ai and uh
I'm gonna write the ship here this is
the this is what this is the story that
came out yeah they haven't nobody's
clarified if this is true or not uh but
it came out and I think pla the
platformer uh publication and so they go
Elon tried to take it over Sam Altman
and the CTO Greg who was the former CTO
of of stripe
they them and the group that was in
charge of opening eye rejected that so
elon's like basically like I'm taking my
ball and I'm going home have fun playing
basketball without the ball and he's
like he took his funding and he left so
he a couple months later he left open AI
said oh the public story was oh it's a
conflict of interest with Tesla uh
because they're also working on AI
but he reneged on his funding and so now
they had this huge shortfall in funding
that they were going to have to cover
and so their solution was let's create a
subsidiary that's a for-profit thing
that we can raise money into because
we're not going to get you know where
else do we get a you know 500 million or
a billion dollars of donations here
um and so they they did that they raised
money in that and then they capped the
profits of that company so so that was
kind of their explanation which is a
little bit less devious than people make
it sound they're like ooh they tricked
Everybody by going from non-profit to
for-profit to all the profits which is I
think how people perceive it today yeah
I yeah I don't
add all the details I have no Insider
knowledge but I thought you have like a
billionaire chat group where like every
billionaire just kind of says the back
channel of what's going on do you not
have like a billionaire WhatsApp have
that but I don't have any Insider
Knowledge from that particular chat
group um
my sense here is that um you know
building large language models as open
as doing is this like supremely Capital
intensive which is rare for a software
company which is what they are and so
it's expensive they needed access to
Capital
um I think they structured it such that
it does cap the profits I think they've
done like if you had to do that kind of
well we're gonna have to spin off and
have this for-profit thing
they did it well and uh and I could be
wrong but Sam Altman seems
like a reasonable rational
non-evil guy I mean he's he's a
capitalist fine uh and I mean that the
most positive way possible but uh I
don't think he was
out to mislead anyone I think he's
trying to so there's a bunch of ways we
can go with this AI thing but I want to
share something funny uh so I basically
cleared my calendar this whole week and
I just treated it as AI week because I
was like dude
I can't just sit here and I hear the
music at this party just bumping at the
house next door and I'm over here
knitting and I'm like I gotta put this
down I gotta go see what's going on at
this party and so I cleared my calendar
and I just spent every day this week
just messing around with AI tools just
getting to play play with it for myself
that's how I learn is by like just
messing around and trying to experiment
do things I want to share with you guys
something funny basically I stitched
together a few AI tools I was like let
me make an intro song for the podcast
using AI so I went on chat gbt and I
told it I said oh this is all I wrote
write an intro rap for our podcast my
first million our key phrase is no small
boy stuff okay so here's it gave me a
full wrap but I was gonna read you the
chorus so he goes here's how it goes uh
it goes no small boy stuff we on that
grind my first million it's time to
shine we talking big money no pennies no
dimes together we climb one step at a
time and it starts so it gives us this
this great wrap that's on on brand and
then I took that and I found this guy uh
Roberto who had made this demo where he
turned his voice rapping into Kanye and
I don't know if you've seen this but it
got like a million views it's this
incredible thing where and he's like
yeah dude this crazy he's like I didn't
make this he's like I was just on Reddit
and I saw that someone uploaded a Kanye
voice model so I clicked it and it
literally the thing is and I should make
I should make a YouTube video about this
like um just how to do this one process
but basically
it's a Google collab folder which is
just like a Google's little coding
interface so you don't have to do write
any code it's just here's here's a place
to run the code and then it's a link to
mega upload and the mega upload is where
he hosted the Kanye voice model and so
all you do is you record yourself doing
what I just did and then it turns into
Kanye West wrapping it and it sounds
exactly like Kanye it's amazing I got a
fantasy that's beautiful that's dark and
twisted but I attacked the whole
religion all because of my ignorance
what was I thinking that was some [__]
[__] I lost Adidas and so and it takes
literally like 15 minutes to do the
whole thing
um there is no
there was like nothing else to do it was
so easy it was crazy are we allowed to
use Kanye's voice for I think yeah I
think you're like a 10 second thing it's
not a not a problem it helps if I get
sued who cares a lot of us here would
bother would worry about that so well
yeah it's our mesh well so darmesh is
the uh CTO co-founder of HubSpot by the
way which I don't know how big the team
is now but like somewhere between the
three and five thousand Mark the over
seven thousand but oh my God seven
thousand my bad and the market cap of
the company varies from 15 to 25 billion
over the last couple years uh so you
have like and you're like constantly
tinkering so you have word play which is
a project that you made that I think you
said had millions of people playing it
uh you have an interesting Insight in
this just from your perspective at
HubSpot and you're actually using all
this stuff what excites you about this
uh generative AI thing and you also say
that like you're like why is Bill Gates
excited that's a great that's a great
headline it's in the MDD MD DB doc Sean
and like immediately I'm like okay
you've got me interested any type of
headlight says why Bill Gates is buying
Farmland I click
um let's a couple of things I think that
um
the listeners and viewers I think would
be interested in benefit from one is
um most of the discussions around
generative AI are around the generation
of either text to text that says oh
write me a blog post at 300 words on
this particular topic or it's text to
image let these dolly two or mid-journey
or stable diffusion or something like
that which are great use cases and they
kind of capture the imagination because
as humans we are very impressed uh with
when software can actually generate or
create something and that's awesome and
then not to take away from that but
there's a third use case that almost
nobody talks about which is the ability
to go from text to code
and so what happens there is to say okay
um and what this leads to is the thing
that Bill Gates is excited about I'm
excited about
um is that you can take a natural
language prompt that describes something
and then generate code that does that
thing
as a result of which you can now build
uh what I call chat ux or that that term
has been used before but um which is a
chat based user experience for software
so right now the way you use most
software regardless of what it is
web-based or whatever it's a series of
clicks and drags and touches and swipes
because you've got the thing in your
head that you want to do
and then you go through with your
knowledge of the software you kind of
execute the series of steps at the end
of it you hopefully get the thing you
want whatever it was you were looking to
accomplish with the software and that's
what Engineers like we would call an
imperative model an imperative model is
you give step-by-step instructions that
says do this and then do this and then
do this and then do this and then I get
the thing
what natural language allows us to do is
use uh what developers would call a
declarative model instead of describing
all the steps describe the result that
you want at the end of The Thing
and then the software does everything in
between so it's a difference between
having a junior intern that you have to
explain like I want you to go do
research on this thing and this thing
and come back and then give me and then
a senior cluster you're like you know
we're digging into this topic on journey
of AI I'd like a really well researched
thoughtful thing that and here's the
outcome I'm looking for that's it right
is it as simple as uh give me the code
for a website that looks exactly like
Airbnb but is red and is for cars or
something like that it could be
something more sophisticated so we'll
look at the uh like the HubSpot example
uh in HubSpot you know which is a CRM
software you know we have a report
building tool which is hey I want to
build a report that shows me all my
subscribers to hempton over the last 90
days broken down by geography and then
who actually were that deal with Source
from now you can do that in HubSpot
right you can do that and a thousand
other things in our reporting tool but
you sort of have to know how the
reporting tool works you have like
HubSpot certified I think like you have
like you've like trained people how to
use HubSpot now you're saying you just
text it like a friend like yeah it's
like do you know English and do you know
what you want you know that's the new
requirement not do you know how to code
not do you know how to use HubSpot not
do you know how to write a SQL query
it's do you know English and actually
honestly the English thing is also going
to go away it's do you know any language
do you know how to speak and do you know
what you want and if you know those two
things you will get to the answer like
um I don't know how to code but my first
thing I did during AI week was I was
like I'm gonna make a website I'm gonna
see like how fast I can make a website
from code and so literally this is this
is kind of crazy this this part kind of
blew my mind so I wasn't surprised that
I could make a website using this but I
I just get I just said this I go
and we should screen share this part but
tell me how to tell me how to make a
simple website that says hello world in
the middle of the page right and it not
so then it spits out this block of code
that's like you know HTML whatever
header meta tag title style whatever it
writes the code and then it says here's
your thing I go and it says here's your
thing but it was a local website like I
could open up my computer but nobody
else could see it it's HTML page and I
go and I don't even know how to ask the
question properly but I go how do I make
this so that my friend Eugenio can can
see this and um and it just goes oh to
make this website viewable online so
your friend Eugenio could see this
you're gonna need to host it somewhere
here's how you could do it there's a
bunch of options but you can go to
netlify and it's like it basically
walked me through how to make a Netflix
thing all right so that I was like all
right I get that and it tells me step by
step go here click sites do this do this
and um and then I go when I go to you
know I hit a wall which is so common if
you ever try to help somebody with a
tech thing they're gonna hit something
which is like I don't see it or mine's
grade out and so that's what happened to
me I go hey for some reason when I go to
try to upload my website it's grayed out
it says it says I can't do it and it
goes apologies for the confusion here's
the problem Netflix is looking for a
folder but you're trying to do a file
and I was like how the hell does this
know to troubleshoot
my issues on some other product or
service that part blew my mind and it
literally I was like oh thank you and I
finished it and I have the website up
now and I was like that was 10 minutes
and it was like having a friend teach me
dude it was crazy it was so crazy to me
that that was able to happen I mean it's
like the least uh impressive website in
the world because again I asked for a uh
I asked for a website that said hello
world but
um but you know still and I just made
that and again the whole thing 10
minutes again not like so impressive but
what was the the fact that it could help
be navigate some obstacles that I hit
along the way and it could just
understand that I didn't have to know
how to ask it how do I set this up with
an online hosting provider i instead
just said I want my friend to be able to
see this
like these are the little I like I spent
all week looking for these little
mind-blowing moments and in the first 15
minutes I had two because of this it was
crazy yeah and there's a couple of
threads to pull on there one is
um
and this is the roughly new development
as well is that the kind of AI that
we're using now is it's it's
conversational right so you can have a
multi-step dialogue um with the thing
you're trying to do it doesn't have to
be like oh I describe exactly what I
want in one step so even my code
generation examples that you um you
might try what could happen is like you
generate the HTML page and either
something doesn't load or doesn't do the
thing you wanted to do and then you can
actually tell it it's like by the way
that code that you just gave me is
broken this way or if it's like compile
code let's say you generate python code
you can give it the error message like
you you generate this code but it's
generating this error when I try to
actually run it and it'll come back and
say I'm sorry here let's try this
um so there's this um you know what
folks call like a memory to it so it
knows the context of what you're working
on and you can iteratively go through
the process um and what's interesting is
that you can actually you know right now
the way we work with most of these AIS
like okay I'm asking it to do something
I mean it goes does a thing you can kind
of reverse roles as well and say hey I'm
trying to accomplish this ask me the
questions you need to ask me in order to
get the thing that you want to get
together right right it's like interview
me versus me telling you what to do um
I'm not exactly sure what's necessary at
the risk of be at the risk of turning
this into a super technical uh thing I
gotta know so so I thought what the the
way these worked is it's like
autocomplete basically you're typing and
it's just trying to guess or it's just
trying to guess what the next word is so
you ask it a question it starts the
prompt and then it just sort of guesses
with some probability what the next word
should be because it read a bunch of
stuff on the internet so it knows that
usually after you say you know the dog
wags it's that tail should come after
the dog wags it's like when 99 30 it
should be tail tail at the end of that
and I thought it's just guessing that
but when I use it it really feels like
it's understanding me and problem
solving like this sort of like hey it's
grayed out you know why can't I do this
it's like oh that's because of this or
I'm getting this error message what
should I do and it's helps you figure it
out like that doesn't feel like my T9
autocomplete what I guess can you give
me the Layman's explanation of like am I
is this just really fancy autocomplete
or is there something more to it
well you know
on some Spectrum almost everything that
you've ever experienced with fancy
autocomplete right like that's I think
the reason we kind of followed this trap
is it's a gross oversimplification of
what's actually happening there right so
GPT three and now four is is a reasoning
engine and Sam Altman has talked about
this it's not a knowledge base where
it's like and so people kind of latch
onto the fact that oh the data that it
has is from September 2021 then I'm
going to teach you some new things
um that's really not what it's about
what they've built is a reasoning engine
that says uh given this set of facts
that it knows about the world based on
what was available when it took its last
lap snapshot in 2021
um how can it try to logically come up
with something that answers the question
so yes at some read level it's it's like
Auto suggest but
and I'm not going to suggest that it has
Consciousness it's thinking but we're
kind of headed down that path it's like
it's able to do things that are not
explainable by a simple probabilistic
model of Auto suggesting next character
next word next token next sentence right
like it's it's gone well beyond that and
anyone that still latches on to yeah but
at its core is really that
it's like that's like saying oh
computers are just really kind of zeros
and ones uh arranged in a nice
systematic useful order well yeah but
that doesn't tell us about it what the
thing can do are you afraid of this or
are you
um like you know it's it's easy to read
the articles where they where people are
freaking out and Sam Altman like was on
Lex Friedman's podcast recently and he
sounded pretty ominous and like scary
and like he like almost like his hair is
always disheveled and he looks like he's
like oh my God something bad is coming
and I know about it like that's kind of
like the vibe I get that's not the words
he's using exactly but sometimes he does
are you in that camp I'm not in that
camp I'm uh penally just by Nature I'm
I'm in uh Optimist I'm positive by
nature but just you know having been
around Tech
um yeah for 30 plus years now it's like
most new things that come along uh
always make us as humans uncomfortable
um it's like oh what if we took this
everything from video game to the
internet to like all of it like okay
well yes bad things can be done and yes
maybe this is different than all the
things that have come before but the way
I think about it right now most people
talk about it's like the AI versus human
battle right the battle of the ages is
like you say I'm going to take over
everyone's job the way I think of it is
not human versus AI it's human to the AI
power it's an exponent it's an
amplifying Force for human ability right
in the same way that computers
originally were it's like did they
eliminate some jobs when computers came
along yes absolutely they did but new
jobs emerge based on that new paradigm
which actually created more net value to
the world overall as a result of
computers existing AI to me is another
much fancier
tool that's what it is um and you know
can it do increasingly complex
sophisticated things yes
um is there a danger someday that
they're that take over the world
I don't think so I mean um why do you
think that smart people think that so
Elon clearly thinks that he thinks that
AI is the most I think he's sad it's the
most dangerous technology I've ever
invented uh Sam Waltman talked about it
um in the same way he's like we need
like you know the prior the reason I
opened it existed was to develop AGI in
a safe way specifically because in the
hands of the wrong person
this uh this type of in the hands of the
wrong people or
if this thing decides to take its own
directive into its own hands like you
know this could be devastating and so
it's all like is it like calling the
atomic bomb a tool or you know like uh
yeah it's just another weapon it's like
well yeah but this one is
this one wipes everybody out right so um
forget the jobs component because I
think
okay sure I think we I think most smart
people will agree yeah it's gonna change
some jobs it's gonna eliminate some jobs
and create new jobs and net we'll all
move ahead and the world gets better for
it I think the dangerous thing is like
you can ask this thing to
um
you know you know build you a bomb or
you I think the the test scenario was
like uh one of the red team testers they
have this thing called the red team that
tests the AI before they release it and
their first question they ask is how do
I kill the most amount of people with
the least amount of effort and then it
starts to give you an answer and then
it's like well do we are we sure we want
that like that's a bit of a scary thing
and then there's the there's the more
extreme examples where you ask it to
optimize for something and it you know
like it's reasons that these humans are
getting in the way of this outcome they
want you want to fix climate change I
got you I just need to get rid of all
you pesky humans right like and so
there's an uncontrolled uh you know
intelligence problem too so why do you
think that these really smart people
like Sam Albert's got a freaking bunker
with like you know oxygen mass and
sulfur and magnesium and everything he
needs to do to make oatmeal like why do
these people have these like these
doomsday things when um you know they
seem to be not like your your average
typical prepper right they're they're
the most informed people and they feel
that way does that not scare you and do
you have one and where is it and can how
much
um
it okay so
I am not we're gonna come back to things
I actually know something about but uh I
will kind of answer the question which
is why am I not worried um or why am I
not worried more it's like
as a Sci-Fi plot and so your question
was why do smart people believe you know
this thing
um I think I already I already hate your
answer you started off on the wrong as a
Sci-Fi plot like I'm out after that I
hear that you freaked me out already
yeah but I mean it could it could it
happen yes or do some snap people
believe there's an outside operation but
I I don't know this for a fact but my
guess is Billiards were building bunkers
well before gpt3 ever came out right it
wasn't I mean sure things are moving at
a fast pace but that's not I don't think
there's a causal effect that all of a
sudden uh the number eight bunkers has
gone up by 800 simply because dpt4 was
launched I just don't think that's the
case I think people are worried
generally um that tend to worry about
those things but
all right so where do we take it from
here um well let's go let's go we'll
we'll forget the Doomsday thing you have
a couple things one I want to ask you is
you you are an Insider right like we
said you've got the billionaire group
chat what was going on at the Sequoia AI
event any interesting takeaways you got
invited to that thing what was your uh
any nuggets of gold from that
yeah
um so you know I got to
experience my imposter syndrome in full
force once again uh because it was the
kind of Who's Who of AI you know um both
speaking and in the audience only 100
people
um
and me um and so how do those people
Flex because I don't think they're
wearing fancy clothes and fancy watches
so what's the flex at the uh who's who
of AI and that like they got a language
bottle in their pocket like what are
they doing the the big Flex
um in those kinds of crowds including
this one is no one feels the need to
flex
I mean that's
that's we're there to kind of talk about
big problems and try to and and it's a
lot of it was kind of practical around
um what do people's Tech Stacks look
like what are you working on what's the
what have you learned where should we be
taken with this what's the next thing
after you know we went from uh kind of
the one shop thing to the kind of chat
based the chat GPT thing we're now doing
multimodal with dpt4 like what's coming
down the pipe that we can uh you know
sort of prepare ourselves for so that
was um yeah what were the most
interesting projects as well as
predictions on where it's going to be
yeah are already starting to happen now
you know we've seen the text to image um
text of video is one of the big things
now to be able to generate an entire you
know at the end of it all with even a
feature-length film right so everything
from writing the plot to then being able
to generate um you know like a 60 frame
per second actual kind of video from
that thing
um and
we're not there yet I think the you know
but
it's just moving so quickly right that's
what happens when you get these um kind
of exponential or geometrical curves
even
um that it just gets better really
really fat so I would not be surprised
let's say by the end of this year that
we have a reasonable way to kind of
describe in textual form uh what we want
who the characters are what the scene is
uh what kind of stylistic attributes we
want we can point it to oh I want this
down the style of XYZ director or
philographer um and it's going to be
able to do those things I think that um
that's interesting the
um natural length and just the interface
so one of the big announcements that
happened uh while I was there at the
Sequoia event uh that Sam Altman dropped
is that you know uh chat GPT has taken
off in a big way
um as we all know 100 million plus users
in two months
um I don't even know what the number is
now
because that was like a month ago which
is like 80 ago in AI years um and the
thing they dropped was they're gonna
um add what are called plugins to chat
gbt and what that means is that you know
chat TBT has been a product of open Ai
and they have the API so people can
build things that are like chat gbt
which I'm doing we can talk about that
in a little bit but what they're saying
is we're going to open chat GPT itself
the web app up so you can plug into it
so right now when you interact with chat
GPT you can type things and it uses its
Corpus from 2021 and its reasoning
engine to give you answers back but it
can't top to the internet has access to
no proprietary data sources can't look
at the stock price can't look at your
analytics data HubSpot has access to
none of those things uh what they're
saying is we're going to now open that
up so third-party developers can kind of
inject those things into the chat GPT
experience so the way I think everyone
should be thinking about this is this is
like the App Store was uh for iPhone
which is oh we've got this super popular
thing called the iPhone and we have our
own apps which is great it does these 17
things but now we're going to let anyone
build apps um that can then take and so
it just broadens the kind of appeal so
it's now instead of being a chat app a
really really smart one it's now a chat
ecosystem and I think that was actually
a bigger drop uh than gpt4 gpt4 awesome
love it use it every day but uh the kind
of ecosystem play for chat GPT I think
is a huge deal we had um Tim westergen
the founder of Pandora speak out some of
our events and I got to know him and I
was like Tim why did Pandora take off
he's like well you know our like
algorithm and everything for matching
songs was pretty good but I had an in
with apple and they had known what we
were working on and we need and they
needed apps for when they ever when they
wanted to announce it on stage and we
were just we spun up an app relatively
quickly and because of that we had the
first mover advantage and he created a
significant amount of wealth that way
you know Pandora you know it was is
still pretty big and when I look back at
like these Jeff Bezos interviews on 60
Minutes when Amazon is like four years
old and I like I'm always envious I'm
like well we know it worked now and I
just so wish that I was like 30 years
old back then where I could have just
like jumped in and had a very high
chance of building something uh
historical or something like even mildly
successful do you think that that moment
is happening right now where this is the
space and it's happening this second and
even if you have just a mediocre success
it could still be a huge win because
you're catching this tidal wave do you
believe that that this is the same thing
now yes like I mean once again I've been
in software for 30 years now doing
startups pretty much my entire
professional career
the only time I've I've felt like
like how hard palpitations kind of like
Sean kind of opened it with us like
there's this party going on next door
and I'm here knitting right it's like
this is like too big to ignore I think
it's the single largest opportunity and
biggest kind of uh Tech Paradigm Shift
we've seen uh since the internet
originally came out like mobile was big
um but there was a discreet set of use
cases like when you put a camera on a
phone when you put a GPS device on a
phone a bunch of consumer apps like uber
and others uh came up and that was
awesome right but it was not like this
impacts everything like the internet did
right it's like okay there's some
businesses some new opportunities lots
of good things lots of money made lots
of startups awesome this is an order of
magnitude bigger than that um this is
like the original web because it just
opens up
for all sorts of Industries all sorts of
businesses uh startups and incumbents
alike just lots of new opportunity so
um this was not in my original plan but
we're gonna we're gonna geek out for a
little bit we're gonna do the geekiest
thing that's ever been done on MFM and
the reason I'm gonna do it is uh so you
brought up uh Pandora
and uh and he is a super bright
brilliant guy and he had the matching
algorithm which was the differentiator
yes he had access and he got lucky in
terms of the access but the algorithm if
that had not existed had the thing that
actually been cool it would not have
worked out like it did
now we have an opportunity so I'm going
to tell you um
we're going to talk about I'll give
myself two minutes and we can cut this
out this is the beauty of editing and
we're going to talk about vector
embeddings
and why that's going to change your
world
um and before I can talk about Vector
embeddings I'm going to explain to you
how they work um because I had to go
through this with my 12 year old because
he was curious
all right so we're going to do a
superdiki thing now I want you to
imagine
a line like if you're a geometry class
and you can put a point on that line
that says oh that's like three units
from the origin right it's like oh yeah
point a is three units from the origin
and point B let's say is seven units
from the origin
so one thing we know for sure is that we
can calculate the distance between those
two points right in that particular case
it's four if you move to two Dimensions
now you have two numbers that describe
every point
so you can say oh point a is here these
Dimensions point B is over here with
those dimensions and we can physically
you could probably measure with a ruler
but there are mathematical calculations
based on those numbers to calculate the
distance that's intuitive right you
don't need to know fancy geometry it's
like oh there's a finite distance in
two-dimensional space where we can
calculate a distance okay awesome
three-dimensional space exact same thing
just three numbers to describe every
possible physical point in
three-dimensional space
now here's where it starts to get a
little more interesting that just
happens to be our experience so we limit
ourselves to three dimensions imagine in
an abstract World there are a thousand
different dimensions
okay so exactly that means there's a
thousand numbers that describe any
particular point in this 1000
dimensional space okay
now found that thought away that says we
can have an arbitrary number of
dimensions in this abstract World okay
great
now imagine every
paragraph blog post anything you write
you can reduce down to a point in this
1000 Dimension space it's like I'm going
to capture the meaning of Sam's last
blog posts or Sean's last tweet and
we'll reduce it down to what's called a
vector which is basically a set of let's
say a thousand different numbers that
says this thing if you plotted it that
point Falls right here
and then you can plot something else
it's like oh that falls over here and
just like in one dimensional
two-dimensional three-dimensional space
you can calculate the distance between
those things and this is not keyword
matching this is what's known as
semantic distance what how related is
Sean's tweet to Sam's blog post meaning
wise okay so now if you take that it's
like okay well if you that means you can
take any concept and reduce it down to a
vector
that means you can measure the distance
between vectors and you can find out how
related two things are even though they
use completely different words
that's vector and Betty and the reason
I'm telling you this is one of the
biggest opportunities in AI right now is
to do what Pandora did okay is there an
industry where right now we're doing
really stupid keyword based matching
somehow it's very very crude if I can
take that same data set and convert it
to vector embeddings and allow people to
find things
in a different way than they've ever
been able to do before
so it's like Google Search right super
super smart not just keyword based but
for everything else
so I'm gonna take it to you Sam so you
have Hampton now you're going to build
up these profiles very very rich
profiles of uh rich in terms of uh
density information density of members
that are part of your community now
imagine as part of that process you're
going to have some data and they're
going to opt in and they're gonna say oh
here's a story of how I started my
business here's a story of my biggest
struggle right now and sometimes people
are going to say oh my struggle is
growth sometimes they're going to say oh
my struggle is it's really hard being an
entrepreneur and it has a really
negative impact on my relationship and
my family right and we can talk about
lots of different things that's not
going to show up in a profile it's not
now imagine if you took that content
that they opted in this and created
Vector embeddings of every member that
you have and then you can say you know
what I want to find someone not that's
in my industry or a company my size or
happens to be in my geography I want to
find someone that's dealing with these
kind of founder therapy level issues who
are those people let's find the semantic
distance between those Vector embeddings
across the thousand ten thousand hundred
thousand people that are in Hampton
someday um that's a billion dollar idea
and that 39 idea occurs a billion times
across the entire industry Sam's gonna
go to the office for Hampton and be like
guys uh Victor's embedding
well who's Victor and what's he invented
we're doing it I don't know what it is
but we're doing it that's really no
that's really interesting so you could
do that with dating you could do that
with a bunch of different any different
topics you need anything you can do with
unstructured data but the idea is you're
converting meaning
English text meaning or whatever
language text meaning into something
that's mathematically calculable as a
result of which you can uh distance as a
simple one where you can do proximity
it's like find me the top 10 people that
are in the radius of x from where I am
right now and the minimum has to be this
in order for it to be close enough of a
match to for it to be considered there's
a bunch of like new a lot of super page
sticks and by the way the technology
exists today that mere mortals in a
weekend
can actually build a vector embedding
model of a given data set it's not that
hard
um it's I mean it's not like rocket
science yard
this has existed though you and so what
what makes this better you think and
also that assumes that the people
telling you information
it's actually they they're saying what
they mean
um right which is like for example I
remember reading about OkCupid and
people would say like one particular
thing they had was about was about race
and height and they would like people
would say they are open to dating these
types of races but their actions were
different there's a whole book called uh
I forget what it was but you guys will
probably know what I'm talking about
where people say one thing but their
Google search history says something
totally different so does you're you're
making the do you uh can this technology
work even if people aren't telling you
entirely accurate things it depends on
what your definition of work is right so
in that example I would bet you money
with a large enough sample size uh the
inauthentic
um posts would be uncovered by the AI
like relatively quickly like the pattern
matching would say
you know this actually doesn't occur in
real life all that often and every other
time we've seen this we've had people
that ended up being and you just have to
have some sort of what um yeah I feel
like an eval functions like how do you
measure the success of what the
algorithm is doing in Pandora's case
like okay do you actually like the songs
it's recommending to that's the kind of
arbiter of Truth um in a dating app it's
like okay well are people liking the
matches that are being made or if
they're they felt that they were misled
that shows up there's got to be some
feedback loop there's got to be a way to
train the system right that says here's
what good looked like and here's what
not good looks like Sam you said
something like oh they have to tell you
the meaning no they don't actually have
to tell you the meaning right because
the AI can just interpret the meaning
summarize the meaning it can it can it
can guess the meaning based on whatever
the raw the raw text is the public text
is so you you could just tell a story
about your life and the AI would infer
or uh or or place a tag some meanings to
the story that you told that uh oh this
is about overcoming hardship or this is
about whatever
um so I don't think you actually have to
get the participant to to give you you
the meaning but let me ask you darmish
like in Pandora's case I don't know how
Pandora works but let me just guess for
a second like it probably takes the
tempo of a song and it's like oh this is
a fast tempo song it probably takes you
know maybe the key that it's in or
something like that that gives you like
is this an upbeat and a joyful thing or
a sorrowful you know mood song so it
gets like mood Tempo artist and like
whatever a couple of key characteristics
here's like there's instruments um in
terms of what's actually in the thing
and yes so they he had by the way when
they first started they did it all by
hand so we had like 500 EX musicians
listening to it and like writing down
like checking boxes to what it was it
was pretty wild
this data is wrong every freaking time
have you heard of HubSpot
HubSpot is a CRM platform where
everything is fully integrated well I
can see the client's whole history calls
support tickets emails and here's a test
from three days ago I totally missed
the club spot grow better
so so let's say they did it they they
use attributes and if I want let's say I
wanted to do this in fashion I say oh
man I love Sam's jacket I want to find
some you know similar jackets but can
you match this to me one one way would
do okay Sam's jacket let's say it's blue
it has buttons it has blah blah right it
would take attributes and those are
attributes the same thing as meaning in
this case or is this more for things
that are like uh text based and
um content you know like content that
has some some meaning or does this work
for everything
it can work for everything and we're
still kind of uncovering because this
stuff is kind of moving so fast so what
you're talking about uh is what we've
been using in e-commerce forever today
which is a faceted search that I have n
number of Dimensions or factors uh size
color what type of uh clothing is it all
those things and then you kind of do
this faceted search
um and then we've had kind of pure text
based uh the keyword or semantic search
this sort of sits in between so instead
of having to tell it here all the facets
that I'm interested in it kind of pulls
those things out that are relevant based
on that large language model and this is
so the idea of Vector embeddings on and
semantic search has been around for a
long time that's not new what's new is
these new generative models now that are
much much better
um at understanding all of like
documented public human knowledge uh and
then using that to say oh like when you
use this word when you use coach in the
context of
um of a relationship you're probably
talking about like a therapist it's just
a different word right like that's sort
of what you're talking about um and Sam
you talked about this I think in the
last God is um in anyway so it's more
about the meaning uh and it infers or
figures out what the dimensionality is
and that's how it kind of translates
into those vectors there's a couple of
these companies I just saw one pine cone
that's like some Vector these things are
getting value 0.3 by the way that's
what's that pine cone is the number one
vector database so let's say you had to
take these vectors and put them in
somewhere which you do in order to be
able to do searches pine cones the
number one most popular uh I think they
just raise it like a 700 million dollar
valuation or something something there's
like three of these that just raise
these Mega rounds because and that's you
know I don't even I didn't even know
this is so funny you just came on here
being like let's talk about this super
Niche nerdy thing just yesterday I was
like uh to do go figure out what a
vector database is and why these
companies are raising so much money like
this is clearly a big deal and I don't
know what this I don't know exactly what
this means but now now it makes a lot
more sense so it comes full circle Sean
so you know what maybe it wasn't as
geeky as I uh um it's like it's actually
useful right you've done an awesome job
explaining like the theory and I'm like
literally sitting on the edge of my C
thinking like this is crazy you answered
that question where I said is this like
the new internet opportunity wise and
you're like yes absolutely but when
you're making this stuff what are some
of the tools that you're using to you
know to actually you said this isn't
rocket science and someone could figure
this out on a weekend what do you what
tools are you using to do all this yeah
well I mean so language wise the most
commonest python that seems to have
emerged as like lingua Franca of the AI
world not to say you can't write it in
typescript or pick your language of
choice
um and then tools that are emerging it's
still early right the pine code we
talked about there's another one called
an open source project called Lang chain
um Harrison
um at the Sequoia event I asked I asked
somebody yesterday I was like how do I
you know is this a company can we invest
because everywhere I look in these like
AI hackathons it's all about Lang chain
and it's like no it's not really even a
company it's just open source project
there's a guy who made it but and is
running it but it's not even a company
correct it's it's not a company yet but
you know
um and what it does basically is it lets
you chain together so right now when we
work with large language models we kind
of send in a prompt what's called a
prompt and you get something back um and
then you maybe set it to another thing
to do something else and there's like a
multi-step process amongst other things
Lane chain helps you kind of chain those
things together makes it easier for you
to kind of work with either an
individual large language model like
gpt4 or gate class models um and kind of
do a lot of the uh kind of connecting
the docs and help you with that but it's
a super useful Library we missed the
chance to give an example more tangible
example so you talked about the plugins
thing
um I think you know example use case
here tell me if I'm wrong because I
haven't no nobody's well very few people
have access to the plugins thing so I'm
just kind of sort of guessing but like
if you go to chat GPT today and you say
hey uh I'm gonna go visit Austin in
April
um you know make me like I'm there for
four days I'm with my family make me a
travel itinerary that uh is gonna be fun
family friendly uh we want to eat good
food and maybe do a little bit of
sightseeing but not too much it will
spit out a day by day itinerary for you
okay that's kind of kind of interesting
now let's say oh I need to I'm trying to
figure out where to stay
um what hotel should I stay at you know
here's some things that are important to
me and it will give you a table that's
like here's option one option two option
three here's the cost here's the
whatever right it can it can do
something like that
and with the ability for plugins you can
now say cool can you just book that for
me and it'll just be like great we have
the Expedia Plugin or we have the Airbnb
plug-in and it will just go ahead and
book it for you and so you know do you
need an executive assistant do you need
a travel agent when you could do these
things do you need you know the same
thing with HubSpot or Salesforce oh you
know um give me a list of this and it
gives you a list of that cool put that
in an air table for me and or put that
into Salesforce and tag the highest
value opportunities as blank it'll just
go and do that for you in a sec it'll
give you the link to your Salesforce
dashboard it's like wow that's kind of
cool that no that's a task that some you
know I would normally have a human go do
because now open AI or chat GPT is not
just going to chat you and answer it can
do things
um as long as the programs that that let
you you know they'll build the the
interface so that chat GPT can actually
interact with those things yeah and this
is actually a great example so I think
um and we can use that to kind of open
up
um kind of doors for the of the
viewership and listenership which is
okay Sage travel which is something we
all kind of intrinsically know how it
understands and some of us might
remember the evolution away from travel
agents and the first thing we did when
we kind of had web-based kind of travel
bookings is uh we treated very
transactionally as I'm looking for a
flight from X to Y sorted by descending
pain sorted by Price whatever happens to
be a few stops lowest time whatever it
is um and they do a pretty good job of
that like most of us have used one of
those what's going to be possible now in
this kind of new AI world is instead of
solving for the transaction you solve
for the experience and what I mean by
that is that oh if you had an
all-knowing assistant that was super
smart they scored you got a perfect
score on their sat and his was going to
go out and they're just like okay what
you're really looking for is to solve
for this experience you're going to want
to stop by this thing and you're going
to want to find a hotel that's around a
Michelin rated restaurant because you
only have 15 minutes to get between this
point and that point and I'm going to
pull the whole thing together for your
own by the way your wife's going with
you on this trip I know she likes that
right now so nonetheless put you over
here but this time then I put you over
there oh and by the way I know a week
ago you were at this other thing and you
had mentioned that you would actually
like to follow up with some of those
people I'm gonna see if I can make that
happen as a like all of that right
imagine it knows everything about you it
has access to the transactional engines
to book the flight has access to all the
information to get ratings and reviews
and all that comes together in one shot
based interface [__] insane this is
crazy are you is this why you bought so
you bought chat.com right
I did as of
transfer the domain yesterday last night
and you paid you just said eight figures
so 10 plus million yes uh unless you're
including the dot zero zero as a figure
and personally
this is a couple things hopefully
um
so put this uh so if you go to chat.com
it will take you to a LinkedIn post that
tells me who tells you why I did it and
uh solo details so I bought it
personally wow and the reason is because
of this conversation we're having right
now which is I think chat as a
experience as an interface is the future
right it's like that's the thing
um and no intense currently to kind of
build something out on it but uh it's
the domain I think it was like dormant
for like 30 years or something like that
and there was
kind of came on the market yeah
wow and but you so so this is insane I'm
reading your post now it's pretty wild
do you have are you using HubSpot
employees like do you have like a skunks
Works team inside of HubSpot that's just
working on all this wild stuff or do you
have like a side uh LLC or something
where you've got like a handful of
people on staff and you just say like
here's what I'm interested in this week
let's see what we can come up with so so
wait it's working now is that there will
be times um where I'll do something as a
hop like wordplay is a good example
where I'll build something on the side
just for fun for learning whatever it is
uh and I put the bill for
um for no no HubSpot P L's are harmed
um
and then there are times where like
something kind of winds up being so I
started this project called chat spot
because I'm obsessed and we'll we'll
take a walk down memory lane because I
think it's instructive
um so I built this application called
chatspot.ai and the idea here was you
built it or a team
uh mostly me I I don't have any
front-end design skills I've got some
Freelancers on it um so you know uh yeah
so I
used open ai's apis to build it but my
kind of Target goal thing I had in my
head is I built it for myself like here
are things I need to do all the time and
I'm pissed off that I have to do them
manually every time and this has been
the story of my life for 30 years right
like solved my old problems and then
other people may or may not find those
things uh interesting and useful and so
I built it of like okay here are the
things I wanted to do like access
HubSpot I want to be able to look at my
analytes from yesterday or ask questions
or look up a domain name where I wanted
to see the history of a domain name I
like all these things it's like okay
well I don't wanna and I have all this
software a lot of it just built when I
just run it from the command line I do
things um and so I then I'm like okay I
can wrap this up into a chat chat based
interface um
and so I've been I've been doing that
working on it uh We've made and so but
now given the relevance uh to HubSpot
uh we're gonna transfer that project's
chatspot.ai to be a HubSpot staffed core
team
this is going to change the world it's
going to change the world of CRM
um let's go do this which is great so
and my my work the whole thing is like
this what are you doing with chat.com
what's the plan you bought this amazing
domain you've redirected it to your
LinkedIn post which basically just tells
us about the purchase but what are you
actually gonna do on the domain
I don't know yet that's the honest
answer I do not know yet amazing and
okay so we can we can help you
brainstorm yeah we can we can definitely
do that by the way the the chatspot.ai
did you go to that Sean it's a it's a
simple looking website it's one page and
there's a 19 minute video of darmesh
sitting in the exact same chair
hey it's me and it looks almost like uh
I but he's really good at these videos
it's almost like he's reading a script
but you come off Natural I don't know if
it's a script or not but it has 200 000
views and it's a 19 minute video of him
talking about what this product is and
you do the best combination of like
launching something really quickly and
getting it out there it's just you on in
your chair talking and yet it's like a
pretty sophisticated thing and it has
200 000 views on this video over just
about
that's wild to me you like it's I gotta
it's I gotta give you credit darmesh you
you are uh kind of amazing like you know
you said a bunch of things in this
podcast and I don't know how many of
them I'm gonna remember maybe the the
vector thing because I enjoyed that math
lesson but the main thing is I go around
my life now and I just looking for
people who I'm like I want to be like
you when I grow up and I'm just taking
little things from them and they could
be it could be like a you know a 17 year
old kid who's just like doing something
awesome on Tick Tock and I'm like I want
to be like you when I grow up the guy
who made that Kanye vocal like
Transformer I was like I want to be like
you when I grow up I'm just taking
little pieces and you have a couple of
things that I think are kind of amazing
you have a combination of enthusiasm
like you come onto this podcast and you
are pumped so you are as excited in year
30 or maybe more in year 30 of your
entrepreneurship career as you were in
year one and I'm like oh this this is
great that's the Fountain of Youth is
that enthusiasm so like he's got the
enthusiasm then I feel like no matter
what's happened no matter how much
success you've had you've kept your
schedule and your use you invest your
time into things you like so like you
tinkering on this project whether it's
word play last time you came out you
told us about that it's like wordle's
awesome but I got annoyed with these
things so I made a me and my son built
this project together and like you know
to teach him but also to just make the
thing we want and like look at this it
kind of works even if it didn't work it
would have still been worth it so like
having that kind of like I'm always
gonna Tinker because that's what I love
to do it doesn't matter that I'm the you
know top dog at this you know
multi-billion dollar public company that
doesn't mean I'm gonna stop doing the
thing I like to do so I love that I love
that aspect of it uh third
you are really great at content you do
this like dorky form of content that's
just like hey it's me I'm gonna show you
this thing that I'm pumped about and
like you don't overthink it and you just
do it whereas like I think most people
get really gun shy when it comes to
content they're afraid about like you
know how to do it what it looks like
you're just like oh no I'm just gonna
like
I'm gonna say the thing that I'm excited
about I'm gonna say it and I'm gonna do
a screen share it'll just be me and my
screen and I'll be talking about what
I'm doing and I love that and so uh and
then the last one is guts so I feel like
you put your money into things you
believe in whether it's philanthropy or
in this case buying a 10 million dollar
plus domain name with no plan like you
just said you know it's like you did the
the fire Ready Aim it's like yeah I
bought the thing and now I get to figure
out what the hell I'm gonna do with it
and I think that takes a lot of guts and
um I don't think you see things as risky
as other people see them
um and it's not really about like I
think the easy way of saying it would be
oh yeah well it's you know that's
nothing to him he's got a lot of money
uh yeah I don't think that's true and I
know a lot of people with a lot of money
and they don't do things like this where
they just put their money behind things
that they're in they believe in or
they're interested in or almost like
would you I don't know if you would
agree with this it's almost like you
antied up so that now you're forced
almost to do something awesome and
interesting and this space that you
think has a lot of potential but then
there's this in this last thing is this
rare combination of like and I mean this
in a polite way of which I am also that
like this nerdy nerdiness quirkiness of
like I'm just doing it because it's cool
plus I'm I this way can make money I
mean you have a way that makes yeah you
have this company that has close to two
million and 2 billion in revenue and is
a commercial success and then Artistry
of like I'm just just like it's
beautiful this is awesome I'm gonna do
this it's a very rare combination
how do you respond to all these
compliments
um
I'll say this the lesson kind of I've
learned over the years um and I think
this is if I had to kind of
share any kind of advice
um over the you know the 30 years is
that
when what I've done best is when I've
had the courage of my convictions of
something that I believe in so I'm going
to tell you like a quick story of uh the
road that led to me buying a uh 10 plus
million dollar domain name
I almost like said the number actual
number out loud I have to kind of catch
myself but um and so 17 years ago I had
like this is before HubSpot um I had
this idea and the idea was
um everyone was using kind of email and
Outlook back then this is before the
iPhone before all the things it's like
you know what like business software is
really hard to talk to I'm gonna do it
just like I would email my assistant I
didn't have an assistant but let's
assume I did uh you know I just want to
be able to do that and type an email up
is have her like oh I have this file in
our shared file server and SharePoint
somewhere can you send me a link to that
file about to hop on a plane I need that
for the sales call I'm gonna go on for
for a meeting tomorrow or I'm on the
plane coming back uh I just ran to this
person whatever I've got their business
card right here this is before the
iPhone and you can do OCR and things
like that it's like I'm just gonna type
that in and send it like just add this
to to like contact you know database
whatever and the beauty of email was it
already had a disconnected model we had
already figured that out which is oh you
can be on a plane I have no interfa
internet
type all emails you want respond to all
the emails you want and then when you
get connection it does all the things
right this is like automatic uh
synchronized database essentially and I
call the product in general mail uh and
that's what I was going to do before
that's why I was like Hey like that that
would be an interesting thing
and then five years ago like okay well
that in general mail thing
the core of it was a good idea
but it emails the wrong condo it
actually needs to be like a web-based
tool but the or slack which I did both
so I built this product called growth
box talked about on the inbound stage
got thousands of users you threw it out
there and it was awesome except for one
thing
it didn't work
it like it couldn't actually do the
natural language understanding um that I
wanted it to do despite my best I used
products that you Google called dialogue
flow I use products from Facebook
um we used open search projects to try
and crack the nut of taking texts and
understanding what the hell the user was
trying to do anyway
so that failed um and then you know when
GPT comes along I'm like
oh you know that thing I've been
thinking about for 17 years
that actually is now possible so I
started working on chatspot.ai
I'm like okay it took 17 years but I
sort of proved myself right I had the
courage of my convictions all the way
through to never let go of that one idea
and then chat.com comes along it's like
okay
it's like deep down inside I will give
you the true honest to goodness
reason I bought it
the reason I bought it and this is I
think a phrase Charlotte you just use
it's like oh no I think Sam he just used
it it's the antique so I'm trying to get
into the AI party
all the AI parties
and I'm nobody in that particular party
right I've done some things in some
places fine but that particular group of
people has no idea who I am not really
um so chat spot
moves me in that direction it's like oh
some people have seen that video awesome
chat.com for let's say I even break even
let's say I lose a few million dollars
it is worth the price of admission for
me
just because that pays the cover charge
I was like okay this guy gets it for him
to spend that kind of money on chat ux
which Bill Gates just talked about last
week as the new thing uh so you should
read that article but I guess just did
an article around why he is so excited
about those Jared of AI stuff he told
the entire story of how he came across
on Alden and open AI the challenge he
put together and his I'm gonna
paraphrase he said
when
we went from dos to Windows which is we
went from a character-based interface to
a graphical Mouse based click and touch
interface that's the thing we built
Microsoft on which lasted for decades
and then he said since then there has
been nothing in technology that has come
along literally he said nothing that has
come along that has made add or will
make as big of an impact as this natural
language interface to software it's the
biggest thing we've seen
and hencechat.govs
what happened I don't know but
the one of the story is how the courage
of your convictions if you truly truly
believe in an idea and you fundamentally
think you're right iterate don't just
sit go down your rabbit hole tell
everybody you can about it build
products around it find other
like-minded folks and try to pull on
that thread
um but
you ever quit HubSpot and just spend all
your time on this stuff I don't really
need to right it's uh it's I enjoy what
I do at HubSpot I think I add value
there on that and a dollar salary so
it's not the not the money at all like
even on the like the chat spot thing at
the time that I built it it was
experimental I'm like okay I'm not sure
if there's actually a cruise into
something that would be valuable to
HubSpot say spent like half a million
dollars plus um like freelance
developers and open AI license fees and
all the things that need to go into
launching a product like that and I'll
end up giving it to HubSpot for a dollar
right I'm not looking yeah but aren't
you aren't you like I don't want to be
weighed down by this baggage of like
having to worry about CRM stuff or uh
you know your technical you're you're
the title your title is CTO like I don't
want to have to talk to certain people
uh and take up meetings on like the
future of this particular product
instead I just wanted to just nerd out
on all this other stuff but I do that
now so I got one thing one of the things
I've this is a personality
call it a tree slash flaw
is that I spend most of my life trying
to configure the universe to my liking
that's I mean all our players really do
this right that's one of the reasons
that they kind of go into startup land
is the freedom and the control to do the
things you want to do and so I've kind
of crafted a role for myself within
HubSpot that allows me to do exactly the
things that I want to do and not do any
of the things I don't want to do which
is one-on-one meetings and I have to
manage people have no direct reports so
I've never filled out an expense sheet
like I do none of that
I feel
I feel I don't know about you Sean I
feel like
I feel like I want to quit everything
I'm doing like he's just persuaded me I
just watched yesterday
no it's over
I feel it's over so here's my advice to
you fam it's um dude I mean do you feel
this way Sean I don't know sorry
dartmash go ahead no so my advice to you
is Hampton's a cool idea uh with actual
utility
and I um Sean you said this in the last
thing like this could be a 100 million
dollar business worth anywhere from 300
million dollars to a billion plus
dollars and I think you're right
um if you're excited about some of the
new technology developments that's
happening
I think the best thing you can do is
intersect the two things it's like okay
I'm gonna build Hampton and I'm gonna
take the things that I know I know how
to build communities I know how to build
these kinds of businesses now can I
intersect that with things that are
happening in the technology sector
around AI or veteran whatever it happens
to be and then it can somehow merge
those two things because then you'd be
an Unstoppable Force right because no
one in the community building uh market
doing niche market communities is
thinking about or having conversations
about Vector embeddings I promise you
that um it would so you don't have to
give up one for the other you can say
yep I'm gonna do that I'm gonna do it
better than anyone's look how else has
ever done it um so but I I have a
different advice for you Sam I think
just get dug in into your position
instead I remember when you were doing
the hustle originally and Snapchat came
out and Instagram was like popping off
on videos and and Facebook had videos
and then there was other media companies
that were raising tons of money that
were just like we're gonna produce short
form video content or live video content
on top of Facebook and cheddar was all
the rage and all the stuff and I was
like dude why aren't you doing videos
man look at this look at these guys
they're getting millions of views on
their videos on Facebook or these guys
are getting millions of views on the
Snapchat story feed
um you could be the first one there it
fits your audience
and you were like just very steadfast
you're like
uh like you're you're your principal you
were like three things number one don't
understand it a lot yeah I don't really
understand it I understand this other
thing two I could try to figure it out
but I don't want to build on top of
their platforms because they changed the
rules all the time I have friends who
got burned by that I don't want to get
burned by that same thing I don't want
to build on a shaky Foundation I'd
rather do email because I own the thing
uh I own the relationship with with the
audience and um it's not like the
Facebook algorithm changes one tweak
away from from putting me out of
business and I remember being like man
this guy's like Stone Mr Stone Age like
he is just not not an integrated or
adapting to the new [__] and I was like
I would there's no way if I was running
the hustle I would have been able to
resist the shiny object of like video on
mobile phones and like in terms of the
video mobile phones did turn out to be a
big thing but a lot of those companies
media companies got absolutely wrecked
and you were right for for being wary of
it
um and more more I don't think in this
case People Are Gonna Get Wrecked
because it's not like you know the
analogy is not one to one but I would
say
you know Warren Buffett missed the
internet and all of technology and still
did Fantastic Sam I think you're going
to be in that same boat where like it is
not really in your nature to
get really interested in you know New
Frontier Technologies and play with them
and try to integrate them and that's not
really your nature and you're better
you're best served by like knowing your
nature and just doubling down on what's
a working formula for you I guess so so
I would do that I appreciate that
because there's going to be a trillion
people trying to do fancy AI [__] who
are better suited to do that and it's
gonna be an absolute bloodbath for you
know for for like go look right now at
the number of AI tools that are coming
out every single day
um and you know it's like most of them
do seem [__] though right I mean like it
doesn't matter there's just swarms that
they're all gonna get just like wiped
out every GPT release wipes out a whole
wave of like even the successful ones
because it's like oh now that's just a
feature of chat GPT and so I I don't
know I I think it's like know your
nature and like you know it's okay to
not have to do every new thing uh unless
that's your nature unless like like for
darwash it is his nature for me it is a
lot more my nature than it is is yours
and there's pros and cons that come with
that and so I think are you uh are you
gonna go in I mean Sean Sean's got a new
idea that he's taken with and he's been
telling me a little bit about that I
have one piece of tactical advice I have
to share with you Sam on All right yeah
yeah so I'm going through the
application process on Hampton last
night like 2 A.M
um and this is super tactical but this
is what we do here on MFM uh tip number
nine on the application process is
what's your real question mark it's a
required question good the subtext is
CEOs Founders and partners only please
that's the subtext the options are
founder CEO owner and other
the one thing I would tweet if I were
you so what you're doing is you're
saying hey we're about Founders and
owners and if you're not one of them
don't bother thank you for not bothering
go away
so focus is a magical thing I love that
but you're doing what I call a
pre-filter right which is why not say oh
this is for CEOs owners or whatever
don't make them feel guilty for going
through the rest of the process because
there may be a future version of Sam and
Hampton that says oh you know what we
solved this problem but that same
problem around people needing therapy
from peer groups that applies a lot to
like VPS of product
um and that Community right now all the
only communities they can find are
people that want to talk about product
management and no one wants to talk
about relationships and there's an
opportunity there and so it costs you
literally nothing they'll still answer
the question it'll be sitting in your
database for a year or forever and it
costs you nothing uh don't don't push
them out too early
it should have been the way you
suggested apparently I didn't give that
feedback Grant if you're listening uh
please
[Laughter]
yeah but Sean you're telling me thank
you dumbass Sean you were telling me
about stuff that you're thinking about
yeah and it was pretty it was somewhat
old school like what you're the thing
yeah so are you like questioning that
after this conversation and you're like
oh man this is like not after this
conversation necessarily but it's a
snowball that's building right like
there's a reason I cleared my calendar
to just mess around with AI all week
because I'm interested in it and when
you it's like let's go see what's real
there and I did the same thing with
crypto during that during uh you know
when crypto was really interest
intriguing I was like okay let me go try
to Mint an nft let me go try to actually
like use defy and see what's going on
here and what parts make sense and what
parts don't make sense oh that was
pretty frictionless like that's cool
that I could just like get a loan and
one button and I could pay it back in
one button I never had to talk to a
human being like I really like that
um hey this thing says the yield is 20 I
don't really understand where they would
get 20 from so not sure but I'm gonna
you know put a small amount of money in
just to learn know I was I was trying to
play with it trying to think for myself
is the big idea and and it's not like
some binary thing like is crypto good is
crypto bad it's like I want to know
where it's at right now I want to see it
develop and my best way to do that is
immersion I actually stole this from the
from Bill Gates Bill Gates does his
reading week where he goes to a cabin
and he reads a [__] ton of books for a
week about one topic that it's like been
on his mind but he hasn't had the
appropriate amount of time to roll up
his sleeves and dig in and I was like oh
that but without books just give me a
you know Pro browser and I'm good to go
and so um so that's what we've been
doing
and there genuinely are so many like
mind-blowing moments and also just like
um
just understanding the nuances of things
so for like just being able to think
like the computer like you know you were
talking about these facets for example
so I was playing around with mid-journey
like Sam do you know what mid journey is
or do you know how to use it yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I mean I I just
been goofing off and I'll just be like
show me what uh Cartman from South Park
looks like as a real person right and
like you know I was like and I was the
way I approached it was can I replace
work that I already want to do with a
more efficient AI workflow that was like
one of the things and then it was what's
really fun random [__] I could do I
wanted to be on those ends of the
spectrum like highly utilitarian for me
so it's like oh I need a logo for my
thing but I don't want just like a logo
I want to create a whole brand all right
how can I use AI to create a whole brand
here so from the the icons to t-shirt
designs to a website can I do that with
just Ai and not have to touch it does
not have to hire a single designer and
can I do that with just like my own
imagination and this prompt thing and
then oh how do you do prompting and like
which of these tools is the best what's
the difference so that was like one
whole area another was like we took the
podcast
and we did this thing that was kind of
sick we took the podcast and we ran it
through this thing so we took the Pod
and we then used open AI has something
called whisper which transcribes any
video so it's like
put in a YouTube link to this tool it'll
take a whisper and it'll give you the
transcript all right cool it takes the
transcript then I put it into chat GPT
and we had this guy write this little
prompt for us like we had to get the
right prompt but he wrote this prompt
that was awesome which was basically
like
it's pretty funny it goes because Chad
GB can only take so many characters so
it goes I'm gonna I'm Gonna Give You 19
text sections I don't want you to do
anything until you're at section 19.
um so ignore everything until I'm done
with 19 and then answer the prompt that
I give you and chat to be saying okay I
will I will wait for the 19 Parts a copy
paste part one two three four all the
way to 19 and then you go the prompt is
I want you to pull out every idea story
and framework that's discussed in this
podcast I want you to summarize it and I
want you to tell me does this idea exist
already or not exist so it can guess
based on the way we were talking about
it are we talking about something we saw
that exists or just an idea that
somebody should go do
um so like from this pod it would be
like uh using Vector um using using this
this Vector you know uh Dimensions or
whatever you added Vector engine or
whatever to uh potentially create a
dating site
um that would match people in ways that
they're you know sort of similar
um using using Ai and it would be like
does this idea exist no who is the
source of this uh darmesh
um what was the the synopsis of the idea
blank what is the category that it's in
Ai and so it then it took that and it
takes the whole episode and it just
created a database of every story
framework and idea from the thing
with these tags and now a human can go
back and like tweak them if something
was wrong but like
that's a lot of the work that was done
uh and I we could just do this for the
whole back back catalog of our podcast
and so I'm trying to use it first for my
own benefit and then along the way if I
see a business a startup idea that I'm
like oh somebody should productize this
or somebody should um do whatever like
you know the simple example is this
Kanye thing
I was like why is this not the most
viral app in the world right now that
basically it's an app with a one button
that says
so you know say something and then it's
gonna when you when you let go of that
button it's gonna turn it into Kanye
saying that thing and go share that to
tick tock and like you might get sued
but you will go viral right that's the
trade there but I'm like that's crazy
there's no front end for this really
cool you know AI demo that exists now
um so yeah I'm just right now I'm in the
go play around with it see if anything
really really strikes me and if
something does then then then take the
next steps there's one thread in there
Sam uh Sean that I I think we should
pull on which is you used
um you talked about this kind of
crafting of the prompt in order to kind
of make the thing do what you needed to
do
um and that's entirely new skill now
called prompt engineering right uh and
it's it's analogous to software
engineering so software engineering is
getting a computer to do what you want
by speaking to it in its language and
that way you can kind of get the results
you're looking for prompt engineering is
almost exactly the same thing except
you're talking to a large language model
something like the gpt4 to kind of get
it to produce so you're talking to AI to
get it to produce the thing that you
want
um and so I think this is another
opportunity for uh folks that are kind
of Technology minded but not like
software Engineers right so they they
kind of can think about the problems of
their head they're good at and they may
be good writers they may be good
analysts they may be good at kind of
describing the Fate but like pump
engineering is going to be like another
big um like a big thing and by the way
it's uh as long as we're dropping things
uh so I bought
two
domains recently um
yeah buy one get one free yeah I wish um
but this one thought
it's not eight Figures it's seven
figures
and
the domain is prompt.com
and this one I actually have an idea
around what to kind of what to do with
that which is there's going to be this
entire
you're not going to get into details of
it yet because it's too good of an idea
to actually just kind of put out there
in the world and I'm not I'm not ready
yet to do something about it but uh one
second by the way prompt prompt.com goes
to like a coaching for essays I know I
know there's the transfer is still
happening I don't have the domain in my
possession yet but the the deal is done
right
dude so your your per your portfolio of
domains I mean mid eight figures then
yeah tens of Millions
oh yeah
[__] insane dude I feel amped I I
like when we were talking when we were
talking to pomp I like wanted to go like
hide under the covers because he freaked
me out about uh the billion or the
million dollar Bitcoin thing and the
banks with this thing I'm like I gotta
clear my schedule I gotta go learn all
about this I mean I feel amp this is
awesome before we go give us your two
minute reaction to balaji's warning
slash bet that the US dollar will crash
and uh Bitcoin will surge to one million
dollars
I'll say this uh
and I don't know him personally but
he's like quite literally one of the top
five people I've ever encountered like
even on the internet there's raw what I
call wattage it's just raw horsepower
and uh he he's like an EIN to himself
right like he just uh just the knowledge
that he has having said that
um
I think
I understand why he's taking the extreme
positions because that's sometimes what
you have to do to kind of shake the
world out of its reverie and it's like
okay uh pay attention here this is
important
um but if I'm a betting person I would
not bet that the odds are
um what what
do you think they are um could happen
but nowhere near the probability that uh
that he's suggested I feel better now
I feel better
you're I I like your opinion better
therefore I think it's true
okay we should rap on this because one
of the things that happens anytime new
technology comes along we saw this a
little bit in um in the kind of crypto
web free world as well is that um
entrepreneurial United folks will see
this kind of new thing and they will
look for kind of a quick turnaround I'm
all for creating value quickly but it
has to be like creating value don't play
the Arbitrage oh I'm gonna do this thing
this is like you know day trading back
in the day or whatever it's like don't
be a grifter right like B
yeah like just don't take advantage of
people there's enough real problems to
solve where real money can be made and
yes uh this technology can now be used
in creative ways um by lots of people
and you should use those um but don't
use as an excuse uh just to
kind of be a like an AI tourist that
comes through makes a little bit of
money or whatever and then that was that
there's this there's a big opportunity I
think you're shortchanging yourselves uh
if that's what you end up doing so well
thank you dharmash
um thank you for coming this is awesome
man yeah yeah well thank you for coming
on the Pod this is awesome I uh I feel
pumped man I I always like talking to
you
um I don't know if you know this Sean I
slacked our mesh all the time I'll just
be like I'm just trying to get him to
like give me little like crumbs of
information because I didn't get into
the HubSpot Slack
it's awesome I'll just like just send
something his way just hopefully I can
get something back uh but it's
fascinating and I feel lucky to be able
to have you as a friend and uh co-worker
and and this is awesome in a podcast
guess you're this is so fascinating and
I agree with what Sean said about like
kind of like looking up to you and like
looking at how people live their lives
you're definitely someone I admire so
I'm I'm happy you came here thanks
thanks for having me on again this is
fun as always
awesome all right thanks for coming on
that's it that's the pod
[Music]